try and make up your mind huh
well good afternoon
yesterday Vladimir Putin recognized two
regions of Ukraine as independent states
and he bizarrely asserted that these
regions are no longer part of Ukraine
and their Sovereign territory
to put a simply Russia just announced
that it is carving out a big chunk of
Ukraine
last night Putin authorized Russian
forces to deploy into the region these
regions today he asserted that these
regions are actually extend deeper than
the two
areas he recognized claiming large areas
currently under the jurisdiction of the
Ukraine government
he's setting up a rationale to take more
territory by force in my view and if we
listened to a speech last night and many
of you did I know he's uh he's setting
up a rationale to go much further this
is the beginning of a Russian invasion
of Ukraine as he indicated and asked
permission to be able to do from his
Duma so let's begin to uh so I I'm going
to begin to impose sanctions in response
far beyond the steps we and our allies
and partners implemented in 2014 and if
Russia goes further with this Invasion
We Stand prepared to go further as with
sanctions
who in the lord's name does Putin think
gives them the right to declare
new so-called countries on territory
that belong to his neighbors
this is a flagrant violation of
international law and Demands a firm
response from the International
Community
we've settled along and I've told Putin
to his face some a month or more than a
month ago that we would act together
and the moment Russia moved against
Ukraine Russia is now undeniably moved
against Ukraine by declaring these
independent states
so today I'm announcing the first
tranche of sanctions to impose cost on
Russia in response to their actions
yesterday
these have been closely coordinated with
our allies and partners and will
continue to escalate sanctions of Russia
escalates we're implementing full
blocking sanctions on two large Russian
financial institutions
veb and their Military Bank we're
implementing comprehensive sanctions on
Russian sovereign debt that means we've
cut off Russia's government from Western
financing it can no longer raise money
from the west and cannot trade in its
new debt on our markets or European
markets either
starting tomorrow and continuing in the
days ahead we'll also impose sanctions
on Russia's Elites and their family
members
they share in the corrupt gains of the
Kremlin policies and should share in the
pain as well
because of Russia's actions we've worked
with Germany to ensure Nordstrom 2 will
not as I promised will not move forward
as Russia contemplates this next move we
have our next move prepared as well
Russia will pay an even steeper price if
it continues its aggression including
additional sanctions the United States
will continue to provide defensive
assistance to Ukraine in the meantime
and we'll continue to reinforce and
reassure our NATO allies
today in response to Russians admission
that it will not withdraw its forces
from Belarus I have authorized
additional movements of U.S forces and
equipment already stationed in Europe to
strengthen our Baltic allies Estonia
Latvian Lithuania let me be clear these
are totally defensive moves on our part
we have no intention of fighting Russia
we want to send an unmistakable message
though that the United States together
with our allies will defend every inch
of NATO territory
and abide by the commitments we made
into NATO
we still believe that Russia is poised
to go much further and launching a
massive military attack against Ukraine
hope I'm wrong about that hope we're
wrong about that but Russia has only
escalated his threat against the rest of
Ukrainian territory including major
cities and including the capital city of
key
there are there are still well over 150
000 Russian troops surrounding Ukraine
and as I said Russian forces remain
positioned in Belarus to attack Ukraine
from the north including warplanes and
offensive missile systems Russia's moved
troops closer to Ukraine's border with
Russia
Russia's Naval vessels are maneuvering
in the Black Sea to Ukraine South
including amphibious assault ships
missile Cruisers and submarines
Russia's move supplies of blood and
medical equipment into position on the
border
you don't need blood unless you plan on
starting a war
over the last few days we've seen much
of the Playbook that secretary Lincoln
laid out last week in the United Nations
security Council come to pass
a major increase in Military
provocations and false flag events along
the line of contact in the Dom boss
dramatically staged conveniently on
camera meeting of Putin's Security
Council to grandstand for the Russian
public
and now political provocation of
recognizing Sovereign Ukrainian
territory as so-called independent
republics in clear violation again of
international laws
President Putin has sought authorization
from the Russian Parliament to use
military force outside of Russian
territory
and this set the stage for further
pretexts of further provocations by
Russia to try to justify further
military action
none of us none of us should be fooled
none of us will be fooled there is no
justification
further Russian assault in the Ukraine
remains a severe threat in the days
ahead
and if Russia proceeds it is Russia and
Russia alone that bears the
responsibility
as we respond my Administration is using
every tool at our disposal to protect
American businesses and consumers from
rising prices at the pump as I said last
week defending Freedom will have cost
for us as well and here at home
we need to be honest about that
but as we will do but as we do this I'm
going to take robust action to make sure
the pain of our sanctions is targeted at
a Russian economy not ours we're closely
monitoring energy supplies
for any disruption we're executing a
plan in coordination with major oil
producing consumers and producers toward
a collective investment to secure
stability and Global energy supplies
this will be this will blunt gas prices
I want to limit the pain to the American
people are feeling at the gas pump
this is critical to me
in the last few days I've been in
constant contact with European leaders
including with Ukrainian president
zielinski vice president Harris met in
person with the leaders in Germany over
the weekend
and at the Munich conference including
president zielinski at every step we
have shown the United States and our
allies and partners are working in
unison which he hasn't been counting on
Mr Putin we're United in our support of
Ukraine
we are united in our opposition to
Russian aggression and we're United in a
resolved to defend our NATO alliance and
we're United in our understanding of the
urgency and seriousness of the threat
Russia is making to Global peace and
stability
yesterday
the world heard clearly
the full extent of Vladimir Putin
Twisted rewrite of History
going back more than a century as he
waxed eloquently
noting that well I'm not going to go
into it but nothing in Putin's length of
remarks indicate any interest in
pursuing real Dialogue on European
Security in the year 2022. he directly
attacked Ukraine's right to exist
he indirectly threatened territorial
formerly held by Russia including
Nations that today are thriving
democracies and members of NATO
he explicitly threatened War unless his
extreme demands were met
and there is no question
that Russia is the aggressor
so we're clear-eyed about the challenges
we're facing nonetheless there is still
time to avert the worst case scenario
that will bring Untold suffering to
millions of people if they move as
suggested
the United States and our allies and
partners remain open to diplomacy if it
is serious
when all said and done
we're going to judge Russia by its
actions not its words
and whatever Russia does next we're
ready to respond with unity
Clarity and conviction
we'll probably have more to say about
this as most if it moves on I'm hoping
diplomacy is still available thank you
all very much
[Music]